This video is made possible by brilliant.
You're going to learn more about brilliant later in today's video,
but if you'd like to learn more about the right now,
you can got a brilliant at all forward slash biographics.
You'll also find a link in the description below.
He was the most influential thinker in world history,
a man whose ideas permeated every sector of society.
He is the father of modern logic,
the inventor of the sons of biology,
and the founder of ethical reasoning.
This body Tonia,
small fragments of his writing,
surviving to our times.
His influence on both the western and the Islamic world has been profound in
this week's by graphics.
We discover the brilliance of Aristotle,
the details of Aristotle's life,
a sketchy.
We know that he was born in 384 BC in the Greek Macedonian town of stuck area on
the north coast of the GMC.
His father,
Nica Marcus was the quarter physician to the Macedonian King.
I'm an interest the seconds it is believed that Aristotle's mother faced us was
descended from Greek aristocracy,
the couple and three children with aristotle being the youngest.
He had assistant named Aaron Nestor and a brother named Ron Ness stores and they
come back has died when aristotle was only 13.
His mother died soon after and he was raised through his teenage years by his
older sister's husband,
proximus by the age of 17 aristotle.
He was sent to Athens to pursue higher education.
They are enrolled at Plato's academy.
Plato was the most renowned thinker of the time who himself had been taught by
the great socrates.
The academy had been found 20 years earlier and was situated beside an olive
grove outside of the city walls rather than a formal school with a set
curriculum and to clear delineation between teacher and students.
The academy provided an informal setting whether master plato was pose problems
to be pondered by his students.
Instead of listening to lectures,
the students were encouraged to engage in dialectic discussion in order to
establish a truth by means of reasoned argument.
The main subjects under discussion,
well philosophy,
mathematics and destroy enemy.
Aristotle studied at the Academy for 20 years,
advancing from students to teach teacher during this time.
He developed a great respect and a close friendship with Plato,
the two men,
however,
they did have some fundamental philosophical differences.
As a result,
when Plato died in 347 bce,
aristotle,
his most brilliant students was not offered the directorship of the academy.
That privilege instead went to Plato's nephews abusive post.
Shortly thereafter,
Aristotle left the academy apparently unhappy with the direction that it was
taking.
It is also possible that he was keen to get out of Athens as a result of the
tide of anti Macedonian send them and in the city,
Iris does a little hand by this time,
developed some important friendships which would pave the way forward for him.
One of them was hmi as king of the Greek city of tenures in Asia Minor.
How many us was a former students at Plato's academy.
Upon hearing of the master's death,
he invited aristotle to come to our tennis irs,
sessionals and assets.
The city which faced the island of lesbos that he became the head of a group of
philosophers establishing a brand new academy.
His focus there was only the observation of the natural world.
He also begins to work on two volumes dealing with politics and kingship.
During his time in Asshole,
Sandra social met,
fell in love with and married the niece of Hmi is named five theists,
soon adult who was born who was also named five years.
Soon,
officer us was attacked by the Persians and gang.
Homies was taken captive and executed.
Iris doesn't lend his family.
They relocated to the island of Lesbos where they spent the next two years.
It was here that he indulged in his passion for the study of marine life.
The work the terrorists were conducted on the islands gave rise to a whole new
scientific discipline,
biology,
the study of life.
He was relentlessly systematic in his classifications.
Creatures they were divided into laundry grieves according to their
characteristics.
This resulted in the publication of three books that minute detail of the
characteristics of living things.
He also studied the ecology of the islands
in 343 BC.
Iris also received an invitation from Philip.
The second is the king of massive dome to come and tutor his son,
Alexander,
who was 13 at the time.
I accepted and moved his family to Macedonia where he became the director of the
Royal Academy.
King Philip had a reputation as an uncouth and uneducated barbarian warrior.
He was proud of his son,
was developing the same strength of resolve and wanted the prince to balance his
strength with knowledge and with wisdom,
and he feared that the instruction that was being provided by the boys too.
It is when you create another version of himself.
It was these concerns that prompted the king to call for the great teacher,
Aristotle or the academy.
Aristotle taught Alexander and other young members of the royal household and a
style reminiscence of the platonic academy.
He instructed them in morality,
in logic,
as well as the arts and medicine.
In addition,
one on one lessons were given to Alexander the only was impetuous and stub and
often challenging and resisting as teacher.
However,
aristotle exhibited a great patient,
says he shaped and molded the thinking of the future,
conquer his superior reasoning,
inevitably one over the prince.
One of Aristotle's greatest challenges was to reign in Alexander's impetuous
nature in one memorable exchange and also the prince.
What the most valuable virtue was that a soldier could possess.
Alexandra immediately replied that it was courage,
but what aristotle last would happen if the war he has excess courage,
cost and to run ahead of his army and face the enemy all alone.
Alexander acknowledge that he would surely be killed.
What though the teacher asked what happened,
and if a lack of courage cause the soldier to run the other direction,
well then he would be a coward.
Came on exam,
just reply by this exchange.
Aristotle taught Alexander the importance of always finding the middle pines and
therefore developing balance in one's life.
Aristotle also educated Alexander in the warrior hero traditions of the past.
He provided the teenager with a copy of the Iliad and is encouraged in the
opponent assuming rulerships conquer the barbarian lands to the East Aristotle
House,
very ethnocentric view of non Greeks,
which he doubtedly passed onto his people.
He viewed them as fits only for slavery.
Ends famously gave this piece of advice to the future and be a leader to the
Greeks,
and they dispatched to the barbarians to look after the former as friends and
relatives and to deal with the latter.
As with beasts or plants,
Iris Delta was able to cultivate in the teenage prints a love of reading and of
learning for the rest of his life.
Alexander remains an avid reader developing a special love for the writings of
homer.
It is claimed the Eland,
all 15,693 lines of poetry in the Eliana by heart.
The princes education at the ends of the great philosopher.
It came to an abrupt halt in 340 BC.
Alexander was the 16 year old out of the throne and he was called to Pella to
rule over Macedonia while his father was off waging war
by 335 BC,
Alexander and succeeded his father as king one visit.
First acts was to conquer Athens,
which paved the way for our results are returned to the city where he had spent
his formative years,
Plato's academy,
which was now run by a former student names and socrates was still the leading
influence on Greek thinking.
However,
aristotle was given permission by Alexandra to start up his own rival academy.
As a foreigner,
aristotle was not able to own property in Athens.
As a result,
he rented a building called the Lyceum,
which was a former wrestling school and outside of the city.
Unlike Plato's academy,
the Lyceum was not a private club for half of the day are still some tutors
which teach that Peng students in advanced topics.
Then the doors would be opened and the lectures and discussion would be free of
charge.
It's open to anyone who wish to attend narrow,
soulful spent the bulk of the remainder of his life.
Working at the Lyceum,
he develops a unique style teaching his students while they wandered around the
gardens of the school.
This gave rise to the nickname peripatetics,
meaning people who wonder about this guy of study at the lyceum was vast.
Aristotle wanted his students to research and write about every area of human
thought from mathematics to biology,
philosophy,
politics,
and the rhetoric.
Students were required to write their arguments down in manuscript form.
These were collected in the lyceums library,
which became one of the first great collections of historical writings,
and sometime during the first few years after his return to Athens,
Aristotle's wife Pythius,
she died.
It is believed that the Persian king upsets the terrorists.
Delta has helped to arrange and aligns with Macedonia.
Had pythius arrest is then executed.
Aristotle.
He was heartbreaking in his grief.
He read the poem of his life that survived,
which he titled an Ode to Virtue in science,
though Aristotle,
he became romantically involved with a woman named her phyllis.
Some accounts states that,
uh,
phyllis was a slave who had been given to aristotle by the court of Alexander,
but this cannot be verified.
The two never married,
but I fill this bore aristotle,
many children,
the first of whom they named Nick and MCASS after aristotle's father have
phyllis remains with aristotle until his death.
During the years that our stuff was established as lyceum metathesis,
former people,
Alexander was very busy conquering the known world as his power grew,
so did his ego,
the veggies that the philosopher has instilled in him with cost aside as he
became increasingly megalomaniacal.
Eventually he proclaimed himself to be divine and requires that all peoples
prostrate themselves before him in all of his status as a living going on
aristotle's recommendation,
his nephew Callis,
the knees had been appointed as an office,
a story of Alexander's Asiatic expedition.
Palestinians was concerned about the kings out of control,
ego and somewhat foolishly let his concerns be known and well this led to his
execution.
Then in 323 BC,
the 32 year old Alexander and he suddenly died soon thereafter,
the pro Macedonian governments.
It was forcibly removed.
The Athenians web now back in control into backlash was unleashed against the
Macedonians.
Aristotle is the leading Macedonian intellect and supporter of Alexander was a
prime target of the new regime and he was formally charged with impiety or not
believing in the gods of the state.
This was the same charge that had been leveled at socrates and it led to his
conviction and his execution,
stating that he refused to allow Athens do sin against philosophy twice.
Aristotle decided not to stay and defend himself.
He fled the city and headed for the islands of your beer where his mother's
estate was located.
He died on the islands in 323 BC.
You have natural causes.
It was 62 years of age.
Now,
normally this is where a graphics video would end,
but there is much more about aristotle to come,
but first I do want to thank today's sponsor,
brilliant and I know ads in the middle of the video.
They aren't great that sponsors like brilliant do make these longer videos,
possible brilliance or assigns learning platform that allow you to learn through
active learning,
which summed up is basically the opposite of that feeling of reading a complex
paragraph about some principle and then just having absolutely no clue about
what they were going on about,
you know,
even though you read it 10 times,
still got no idea what's happening and brilliant.
Don't just cover the basics or they totally covered those as well.
They go all the way through to really complex things like advanced statistics,
brilliant,
makes even complex statistical concepts,
very easy to understand,
but they're giving you something super short to read.
It's easy,
and then you've immediately apply what you just read to a problem and rinse and
repeat and boom.
Suddenly you understand stuff that you didn't really think it ever be able to
understand.
I've used brilliant to do just this.
It's pretty amazing how quickly you grasped such complex subjects.
You can spoil biographics by going to brilliant.org,
forward slash buyer graphics,
and now let's get back to aristotle.
Yeah,
Aristotle had died as an enemy of the state and so memory of him,
it was discouraged.
However,
his students and friend Theophrastus kept says,
writing secretly hidden while also taking the reins of the lyceum.
The works of Aristotle did not see the light of day until the beginning of the
first century BC when they became appreciated throughout the Roman world.
After the fall of Rome,
aristotle became familiar to the Islamic world as well,
where many thinkers,
if the time came to appreciate,
is logical deductive methodology.
In fact,
it was largely because of his popularity and the Byzantium worlds that
aristotle's teachings were able to survive the dark ages.
It was during the 13th century.
See this,
aristotle was reintroduced to the west.
This was achieved primarily through the work of Thomas Aquinas,
who attempted to amalgamate religious beliefs with science and philosophy.
Aquinas incorporated Aristotle's assertion that a wrath lies at the center of
the universe as a fundamental tenets of Catholicism.
During the renascence and reformation years,
a succession of religious reformers and scientists began to question some
aristotle,
he and beliefs that had been absorbed into the Catholic church.
One of them was the Italian astronomer,
Galileo,
who presented observational proof that the earth orbiting the sun.
It's ironic that while aristotle was undoubtedly have embraced this new
observation the Catholic church fathers made,
Galileo appeared before the inquisition and recant a session.
English physicist William Harvey later discovered that internal organs don't
work the way that aristotle had status.
Another of Aristotle's views that was disproved was that decay only happens on
the Earth while the heavens never change.
Nineteenth Century astronomists Lord Calvin challenged this notion with the
concept of entropy,
which states that all matter,
whether earthly or heavenly,
will eventually decay.
Aristotle also told the planets and stars are all encased in crystalline
spheres.
Each one nested inside the next with the earth being the intimate sphere by the
18th century.
The contradictory idea that the planets hang on a void was gaining acceptance.
Aristotle wrote some 10 million words in order to preserve his thoughts.
Unfortunately,
the majority of them have not survived the passing of the years.
The manuscripts were been covered in the first century BC when they were edited
by a man named Andronicus.
The works that we have today are derived from Andronico's as edited versions,
and so we're not directly prepared for publication by Aristotle.
Today,
we are able to read about a million of Aristotle's which represents some 20
percent of his total work as a result of the paucity of writings that we have,
we are only able to see a shadow of the brilliance of aristotle.
The quality of the pros,
which has been lost to us,
was hinted dance by Roman statesmen Cicero.
He went declaring aristotle's ratings to those of Plato declared.
If Plato pros with silver,
aristotle's was a flowing river of gold.
The works of Aristotle that have survived are grouped into four categories.
First is the organization in which quantify a set of logical principles to
follow when conducting an investigation then comes the theoretical consisting of
a range of treatises on the natural world.
The practical mechanic refocuses,
focuses on achieving excellence within the individual,
the family,
and in society.
Finally,
the rhetoric writing collect together,
aristotle,
surviving political and philosophical speeches.
Aristotle divided the sciences into three categories.
The productive,
the practical and the theoretical productive sciences encompasses such things as
building an architecture,
but also battlefield strategy in courtroom tactics.
There's also practical sciences which cover ethics and guided behavior.
The theoretical sciences,
which included mathematics and physics and full of the quest for knowledge and
understanding is that own end results,
the scope of Aristotle's scientific research.
It was staggering.
His writings feature minute descriptions of more than 500 species,
some of the features that he observed.
We're not verified until the invention of the microscope.
Thousands of years later,
his detailed observations included the Anatomy Dot,
habitat and reproductive system of the fish,
insects,
and animals that he observed.
While on the island of Lesbos.
A trademark of Aristotle's thinking was that evidence was the ultimate arbiter
of truth.
Regardless of what theories you may hold.
If observation proved them wrong,
then yeah,
must have the humility to discard them and go with the evidence.
Despite being challenged with impiety aristotle,
he did believe in God.
However,
his God did not create or control the universe but could affect it.
He viewed God as the ultimate abstract reason.
I considered that the highest level of attainment for a human is to as closely
emulate God's ability to reason abstractly as possible so the person could get
to this heightened ability to reason the closer they would be to God himself.
Aristotle's greatest contribution to mankind was that he provided a methodology
by which to find solutions to problems rather than providing the solutions
themselves.
When he did come to conclusions,
he was careful to qualify it by stating that the conclusion was based upon the
evidence available at the time.
If new evidence was to come to live so that proved his conclusions wrong,
then he would discount them.
However,
during the period known as the Christian Middle Ages between 476 and 1,453 ce,
Aristotle's methodology was cast aside and the focus went squarely on his
conclusions,
which contrary to his wishes were accepted without question.
So rather than observing nature to find the answers,
they simply accepted what aristotle had written on the subject.
Plato and Aristotle ended up with very different philosophical approaches.
Plato was the ultimate idealist,
but leaving the world around us is merely a collection of ideas.
On the other hand,
aristotle was a realist to believe that the only reality was the physical world
which we inhabit.
Each man would provide a work of political philosophy.
In Plato's case,
it was entitled the Republic,
while Aristotle called.
Here's the politic.
Plato's work was focused on achieving the ideal state.
He believed that one way to achieve this was through the eradication of private
property,
the family and gender roles.
By doing away with these societal norms play,
Jay was hoping to transcend human selfishness in order to achieve social unity.
Aristotle,
however rejects it,
the end goal of Plato's ideal state,
he contended that selfishness is a part of human nature.
His idea was to design a government that acknowledged human selfishness and it's
putting in place checks and balances to mitigate it.
He pointed out the impracticality of Plato's views asking such questions as who
would look after the children if they weren't part of a family.
If other contended that human selfishness is one of the driving forces that
results in achievement.
Aristotle devised a working government he referred to as policy and it was
balanced between the rich and the poor with neither one dominating the other
end.
People were forced to work together for the overall good of society while
retaining their property rights.
One of the hallmarks of aristotle's method of arguments was logical developments
where each point builds upon the last.
This was very different to plato who would jump all over the place with his
ideas.
In contrast,
aristotle emphasize the need for mental discipline by which those engaged in
debate would stay focused on the topic at hand plays.
I was mainly concerned with the accumulation of knowledge.
He believed that ideas were subjective and could be influenced by personal
views.
Aristotle on the other hand was focused on observation and the examination of
what is real.
He was an objective thinker who did not allow a place for emotion or personal
opinion play,
so was an idea list.
He believed,
for example,
but knowing good was enough for a person to do God.
Aristotle,
however,
argued that knowing good was not good enough,
a person had to practice being good to benefit himself as well as society plays.
They also believed that every concept has an ideal form,
whereas aristotle was a view that every concept and needed to be studied on an
individual level in order to understand it.
Plato was of the view that reasoning and thought experiments were sufficient to
prove matters.
Whereas Aristotle relies upon direct experience as a results of their differing
approaches.
The scientific contributions of aristotle were much greater than those of us
teacher Plato.
The lastest teachings were predominantly theoretical,
lacking practicality,
whereas aristotle,
he's left us with the scientific method which grounded in practical observation.
So I really hope you found this video interesting.
If he did do,
give us a thumbs up below and please don't forget to subscribe.
If you want to see more biographics,
we put out several videos just like this,
so hit that subscribe button and hit that notification bell.
If you actually want to find out when we put our videos,
youtube doesn't work how it used to and if you want to see something else by us,
we got some videos from the archive link to you on the screen and as always,
thank you for watching.